the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys two down bring it up 3.com bags are
definitely going to happen in the
upcoming season there are a lot of
surprises so without further ado let's
just jump into it let's start with Jorah
Mormont whose faith was unknown as
prevailing to the nearest his gray scale
along with the statement that he doesn't
know if a cure or how long this takes
but that he will and things before he
becomes a stone man along with
confession about Tyrion Lannister being
right about his love to Archer who
misdemeanors tearfully commanded him to
go and find a cure for his disease so
that he could be by her side when she
takes the Seven Kingdoms back well it
seems that Jorah managed to find a cure
since we have a lot of leaked photos
which are confirming George unification
with the nearest in Dragonstone in the
upcoming season while the crew was
filming is Zumaya juror was seen talking
to Tyrion as the nearest approached it's
called by the tracheas regard and had a
conversation majora we can see from
these leaked photos joined the nearest
shared the talking scene in which danny
says farewell tour advisor winner turn
vows to the screen at the singles on the
nearest turns 2john meanwhile George
helps some men to prepare the boat these
men as you can see in the folios are
double sink injury will also be back in
season seven after long absence that
scene doesn't surprisingly as John
novels ginjury and Jorah push the boat
and went away together to the north to
be on the wall to try to accomplish your
mission which are explained in details
in one of my previous videos now that we
know that your will be back and they'll
be by Danish side there's also raising a
question the juror cookie's grayscale or
did he fail in his mission but to return
to deney any way to help her as long as
he can before it spread that much until
it makes him kill himself well we have
to wait a little longer to know the
answer on that question my guess would
be that he will definitely have his
grayscale cured at a time here in IV
Daenerys this opinion of mine is
basically created while rewatching
episode 5 of 6 season in majora revealed
his disease a scene in which we could
see juror keeping distance between him
and the nearest in order to avoid
impacting her
while he was keeping a distance in that
scene is some occasionally photos in
which we can see him standing near
tyrion and the nearest and later also
sharing a small bolt is jaundice and
injury all of this proves the drivel at
its point already have his disease cured
at least that's how I see it I'm also
wondering how jurors going to cure his
gray scale there's a possibility that
Semel will learn more about gray scale
well as the Citadel and they'll discover
how to cure it while more likely
possibility would be that girl pine a
mysterious woman known by the name of
Quade who have seen in the second season
and who seems to have some special
capabilities by special capabilities I
mean some sort of supernatural abilities
since she knew about juror being a spy
for King Robert and also knew who stole
the nurses dragons and we can call it
reveal to Jorah the sorrows zoom dark
souls and Fiat brie were behind it it's
also important to remind of scene in
which your visit quaid while she was
painting a sailor to protect him while
passing across mobile area with a
statement all who travel close to the
dual marks hell protection let me also
highlight one fact which is confirmed by
custom designer Michele clapping
according to platen crates mask was
designed to display is holistic linked
to Melisandre because both of them are
from the region of a shy all this led me
to conclusion that quaid might cure
Jorah supported by fact that she knows
how to protect people from gray scale
meaning that she might but only might
know how to cure the same jurors
comeback is a confirmed fact well i
still don't know who your Xavier will be
but in my opinion there are only two
options insider similarly orc wait now
let's focus from older phrase come back
in season seven according to the
official agency resume of an actor David
Bradley to us known as Walder Frey he
will appear in the upcoming season of
Game of Thrones last time so older he
was enjoying in a piece of pie made of
his sons burp on event in a state of
shock once he realized it's a human made
pie and was shocked even more once Arya
Stark took of a mask that she stole from
the whole of faces and revealed her true
identity coward Walder Frey attempted
k from the Justice attempted to renovate
from Arya Stark but couldn't stand a
chance against skill killer Azaria is
and gets pulled back following off his
throat being slit open let's also
highlight that those two sons of water
afraid that are killed dismembered and
baked into a pie the same pilot arias
serve to their father we're responsible
for the death of her mother Catelyn
Stark Aria by this act avenged the red
wedding avenge the death of her mother
and her brother with smile on her face
by watching the satisfaction as
vulnerable adult and died you're
probably wondering right now how could
Walder Frey be back after that after
Arya slit his throat open well Walder
Frey is not coming back but he stays
forever role in season 7 in conclusion
we can expect to see probably in first
episode of the upcoming season are you
wearing bowler space and most likely
killing remaining phrase / pawn in my
opinion she will release her uncle
Edmure Tully who is phrase prisoner in
one of cells as Walder Frey mentioned
himself on the celebration now let's
talk about the comic of ginjury who will
finally appear in season 7 after long
adsense dangerous appearance in season 7
became a certain thing a few months ago
when filming took place from Marilla
beach in Baraka as they could see a
ginjury killing two gold cloaks with his
father's Warhammer after which Tyrion
and that was escorted him to Dragonstone
let me just say that is not surprising
that ginjury will be at king of landing
in the first step cells of the upcoming
season considering the last scene of
ginjury in which doubles saved him from
being burnt alive by sending him away in
a rowboat and told him to keep growing
until he comes to King's Landing on
which ginger at first said that the gold
cloaks are looking for him pointing that
he wouldn't be safe over there the Davos
convince him that he's going to be saved
so the gold quotes don't know how he
looks like a few months ago we've also
witnessed a few leaked photos which can
be considered as some kind of league
scene since Lee photos covered every
single detail of the filming this scene
started with conversation between Jordan
Aries in which danny said farewell tour
advisor who in return valve to his clean
as a scene was going on the Near Eastern
to John whereupon they had a short
conversation
those two were having conversations or
help some man who prepared the boat this
man as we can see in the photos argh
injury and Davos the scene ended
surprisingly as John Davos Jiraiya and
ginjury push the boat and then together
and John admission on a mission that
will be highly dangerous on a mission
that most offense rejected that soon as
lake blood came out but also mentioned
that became confirmed as the time was
passing this mission will determine
theta Westeros along with a few
casualties along the genome of getting
killed but at last moment saved by his
uncle same uncle dick has already saved
brand from certain that all details
about this mission you can check out the
single click over here all of these
leaked photos are not only confirming
injuries huge comeback but are also
confirming injuries huge role in season
seven I won't talk much about the ganger
in this video because I've already made
a video about his faith in the upcoming
season which are including Oh leaked
photos along with my predictions about
his huge role in the last eight season
if you're a fan of injury I'm
recommending it to also check out my
previous video in which I provides all
proves that are going favor to theory
bug injury being son of Cersei and
Robert Baratheon supported with a few
hidden hints that show gave us among
those big comebacks I'm also going to
introduce you with new actors and
characters that will have a role in
season seven Game of Thrones will have
enough to render actor in the upcoming
season it's Jim broadband who is going
to play mysterious but a major role will
scare achter he's going to personate is
unknown in my opinion considering
profile characters that HBO was looking
for on the cast for season 7 broadband
to impersonate mr. Marvin next actor
days going to appear in the upcoming
season is Joseph Quinn Quinn will play a
character named Conor a character that
does not exist in the Song of Ice and
Fire novels so we'll have to wait a
little longer to get to know who Connor
is let's continue with an hourish actor
Paul ward who we know for sure is going
to appear but we don't know at least not
yet which character he is going to
portray next actor that will have a role
in season 7 is tom hopper hopper is
going to portray deacon Talia's recast
dick entirely was previously portrayed
by Freddie stroma but upon being unable
to attend
shooting because of his other filming
obligations he is replaced the last new
actor that is going to have a role in
Game of Thrones is an irish actor philip
O'Sullivan who will play a citadel
masters role among those new actors
there's also one actors that is going to
appear in the upcoming season it's an
English actress megan Parkinson I don't
know for sure which character she is
going to portray but one is certain she
will personate a northern girl in
conclusion girag injury and Walder
Frey's face are the most important
combat that are going to happen in
season 7 let me know your opinion on all
of this in the comment section down
below who do you think will cure joris
grayscale and let me know your opinion
toward sorry I using her Faceless Men
skills to assassinate remaining phrase
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in an extra
piece
[Music]